baseball here we are where it was p3 our
friend
rodney hooked us up with this amazing
sports science facility we're going to
put you guys through some testing today
that we would put
any pro baseball athlete through
actually i played little league baseball
up until about
fourth grade the pitching started
getting faster and i got
scared i never got to the level of
baseball where another human throws the
ball at you coming into this
i am coming in like a baseball virgin
have you ever
swung a bat before i've never swung a
bat i mean
really i'm the only one of us that even
play sports and now
i got a broken i can't even participate
i don't think i've ever held a mitt
honestly just just tear just horrible
the goal for today is to not sprain
anything i just want to come out of here
in one piece this is the wrong hand
it goes on if you're ready
it's gonna be a fun one
most of everything we do in baseball
we're going to start off with the
lateral stance we're going to look at
how much horizontal force that we can
create
we want to see how much lateral drive do
you guys have and then how much
can you actually apply in a sport
specific baseball manner so you guys
have seen that make a video game before
same technology we're going to like get
motion tracking on it benny hit the
lights
that's so cool so basically all force
plates are they're high-tech scales
right they tell us
how much force you're going to be
putting into the ground in real time as
you go through any movement midichlorian
rate
all that kind of stuff i feel like a
superhero
standing on this plate pushing off your
back foot how far out can you go
go keep go go keep go all right 6.87 for
key
that's a good number
look at that face man with the 6.9
the average baseball player is putting
up a little over nine meters per
kilogram
a little far below so how are we going
to succeed on the field
it's got to be the it factor computer
can't tell that
base running you have to wait till the
guy hits the ball in this case with the
left-handed pitcher on the mount
since he's facing you not sure if he's
throwing to the plate or he's trying to
pick you up
so we're gonna run through a couple
scenarios where he's either gonna throw
at the home and you're gonna try to
steal
or he's gonna try to pick you guys off
you guys are gonna try to dive back in
safely i'm excited
in that sort of fear-driven excitement
you know i don't really pose a threat so
why waste the pitch
giving him the steel
out signals up man hand up my doctor
would kill me
when we talk about baseball it's just a
drop dead rotational ballistic power
sport
this machine is going to measure how
much rotational power that you guys can
create so let's just warm it up nice and
easy okay
remember outside hand on the first
inside hand step away feel the
resistance
pick up your front foot we're going to
swing it around
god damn it eugene peak power for you
eugene
1062. i feel like if i make a warrior
grunt when i do it it'll help
let's see 761
feels about right compared to our
physical fitness the average for a pro
baseball
is around 2300 damn no matter what this
number is
we also have to be able to apply that to
a moving ball that could be
90 to 100 miles an hour we have a
fraction of a second
as a hitter to identify if the pitch is
going to be
a strike and then we actually have to
hit it i think
that this is going to end very poorly
for me um
nothing i just learned that these balls
can go
well over 100 miles per hour with these
professional pitchers dylan axelrod
starting pitcher with the cincinnati
reds nothing that we did in the lab
tells me i'm ready for this
that is fast all right here we go you
can hear you can hear
the balls friction from the air it's
like the ball screaming after it's been
like spanked
you know it's like
who needs this zack
i think it's time to head for the
cooldown party we'll focus on uh
regeneration what's the cooldown party
whoa all right here we go
what did we learn today baseball is a
hard sport
takes a lot of training oh my god this
is cold
i didn't hurt myself this is like a huge
win for me oh my god
cold on my butt this feels fantastic
america's pastime people think that
baseball is a slow game when you watch
it on tv it feels slow
there is a lot of athleticism involved
numbers and sports science you have to
be so fit to do it it's so fast it just
happened you're blinking it's done oh
is it is it over you're done thank
goodness it's ending
the call never bothered me anyway today
was crazy uh special thanks to p3 peak
performance project
the lab westmont college baseball and
all the amazing players and coaches who
helped us out
until next time what will we try next
are we not doing that this time no no
this was about baseball